عندما تقع في ازمه وضيق نفسيه ستجد من
يوسيك ويرفع من معنوياتك لتخطي الامر منهم
من يطلق عبارات التحفيز بروح التفاؤل
ويدعون دائما الى التمسك بالنظره
الايجابيه حيا لكل شيء هذا شيء حميد لكن
خبر عالم النفس اكدنا التظاهر بالتفاؤل
بشكل دائم قد ينقلب يتعاسه تشير دراساتهم
الى ان مصطلح الايجابيه السامه او
الايجابيه الزائفه هو تجاهل الامور التي
يجب مواجهتها ما يتسبب لكافه المشاعر وعدم
التعامل معها بالشكل الصحيح الايجابيه
ازاي في موضوع فقره الصحه النفسيه اليوم
مع معك
في ما يلي بعض النصائح لتقديم دعم ايجابي
دون ان تكون ضارا او ما يسمى بالايجابيه
السامه او الزائفه اولا ان تكون صادقا في
تعاملاتك مع الاخرين تجنب استخدام
العبارات المبتدله التي قد لا تكون مفيده
مثل لا تقلق كن سعيدا وكل شيء يحدث لسبب
الماء ثانيا تقبل مشاعر الاخرين وتجاربهم
وعدم اصدار الاحكام عليها تتجنب محاوله
اصلاح او تغيير مشاعرهم شجع الاخرين على
التعبير عن مشاعرهم وافكارهم وطلب
المساعده اذا احتاج اليها تاكد من سلامتك
العاطفيه قبل وضع وجه سعيد على الاخرين
تواصل مع مدربا او مرشد او معالج لمساعدتك
في اعاده صياغه الافكار والانماط في كيفيه
التعامل مع الايجابيه والسلبيه على كل حال
سال الناس ما الذي يجعل الشخصيه الايجابيه
شخصيه تامه متابعه الاجابات
[موسيقى]
ممكن يعني يواجه مشاكل بالعمل شغلات هيك
تتحول للحاله عنده فورا ظروف الاقتصاديه
عندنا الوضع الاقتصادي الامور يعني ممكن
شخص مثلا ممكن يزعجك يعني انت نازله مبسوط
امورك تمام نشوف الشخصيه انت تحول الى
امورك امور سلبيه فيها اصحاب طاقه ايجابيه
وما يحاول الموضوع دائما الى طاقه سلبيه
وطاقه ساميه عن طريق الانتقالات السلبي كل
شيء عندهم سلبي تطلع الصبح سلبي حتى تصحى
من النوم وفي ناس بيصحى من النوم لا اله
الا الله محمد رسول الله يا ميسر يا كريم
يا فتاح يا كريم بيروح باتجاه الانتقال
يتعرض انتهاء حقوق لظلم لعدم عدل الى عدم
مسواه مثلا انا شخصيه ايجابيه مثلا همم
[موسيقى]
المحيط اللي حواليك البيئه اللي انت فيها
شوف البيئه اللي انت فيها سلبيه لو مهما
كان عندك طاقه ايجابيه لو مهما روحك
ايجابيات تحول بني ادم سلبي
الناس اللي حوالي الاحباط الظروف الاقدار
وبالمقابل اي شيء بالحياه بده شحن
والانسان اهم مكون لازم نضل نشحنه
يعني بتكون من الاساس غير الواحد مش متعود
على صدمات او احيانا صدمه
كبيره للناس اما صدمه بناس بكونوا ثقه
فيهم او احيانا في الدراسه احيانا في
العمل فهي من الاسباب الرئيسيه
[موسيقى]
على كل تنضم لنا في الاستديو فاتن عياش
اخصائيه في علم النفس الايجابي ومدربه
حياه معتمده من الاتحاد العالمي للتدريب
فاتني يسعد صباحك نورتنا صبغه عربيه
فاتن متى تتحول الشخصيه الايجابيه الى
شخصيه سامه
كل شيء زيدان
يعني ننكر انه نعترف انه في اشياء مش
مضبوطه في اشياء سلبيه عم بتصير بالحياه
ونحن عندنا هذه التيود انه لا كل شيء تمام
[موسيقى]
انه الشخصيه الايجابيه التي تتظاهر دائما
بالتفاوت تتظاهر اه يعني بنحكي عن الشخصيه
زائفه قد ينقلب الموضوع معها الى التعاسه
هل بسبب كابتن مشاعر صحيح صحيح لما دايما
نحن عم نكبت مشاعرنا
ومنفرج انه همم في شيء مش مضبوط ونخبيها
المشاعر تحت السجاده او مش ضروري مثل ما
بيقولوا مفكرين انه راح تختفي فجاه ما راح
يصير هيك همم لازم احنا ك- همم اخصائيين
علم نفس الايجابي نعترف انه في اشياء مش
مضبوطه او في اشياء سلبيه
ونوقف عندها
احنا بشر يا فاتن ساعات الظروف او المشاكل
تكون اكبر منه اكبر من طاقتنا في هذه
الحاله كيف يمكن ان نتعامل بايجابيا من
دون ما نكون تكوني ايجابيه زائفه يعني انت
عامل مع المشاكل بيروح الجميع اوكي هلا في
عندنا اكيد همم
همم انت ما قلت همم امرار همم
يعني همم حالات بتكون صعبه نحنا همم
نتعامل مع فكيف فينا نتعامل مع الطريقه
جيبيه همم مرينت دماغنا لانه نشوف
الاشياء الكويسه من الموضوع
وبصير هي تمرين للدماغ انه نشوف الكبايه
نصف مليان مش الفاضي همم
مثل ما بيقولوا كل كل غيمه في لها سيلفر
لاين في لها ضو وفي قلق نور فنشوف وين هذا
النور همم
[موسيقى]
ساعات مش مشكله تكون صغيره جدا ولكن في
هناك شخص دفاعاتها من اول المشكله في هذه
الحاله متى يجب ان نتواصل مع مختصين
للتفكير بايجابيه والحل الامور
لما سيره تاثر على حياتنا الشخصيه او
العمليه لما نحس انه احنا ما تدرين نكمل
حياتنا همم هون
بحاجه
نتوجه ونشوف كيف فينا نحل هذا الموضوع
لانه نعيش كمان
بالتعاسه بالحزن او بالخوف همم او بشعور
بالذنب او كلها مشاعر سلبيه همم اذا كل
الوقت عايشين فيها وما قادرين نتطور ونشوف
همم شوفي حياه احسن من هيك هون وقتها لازم
دفنت ليطلع على طيب فاتن بحكم خبرتك
بالموضوع في ناس طبيعتهم شخصيتهم ايجابيه
وفي ناس اسمها ما يكون مهما يصير كل يوم
متفائله كل يوم تتطهر انها عم تدعم في هذه
الحاله كيف نفرق بينهم بين شخصين انت
التظاهر
لازم نكون همم واضحين مع نفسها
همم
ايجابيين ولع من مثل على على المجتمع اللي
حوالينا او جميله عن الاشخاص اللي عم
تتظاهر يعني هون بنروح على الايجابيه
السامه لانه بيكونوا مش صريحين مع نفسهم
مش صريح نفسهم طبعا طبعا لانه مفكرين اذا
نحنا خبيناها بهذه الطريقه الامور راح
تختفي الوجع راح يكون موجود وجمال انا
دائما انا بقول انه اذا في حدا عنده هذا
البوستيفز يقول لي ابروتتش لهالحياه ما
بتعتبره انه هذا الشخص اكيد موجوع كتير
كتير وما قادر واجب هذا الوجع وبالتالي
بحط هذه الماسك انه كل شيء منيح الامور
طيب الامور منيحه بس هاي مش الحقيقه